en vinaigrette en quiche ou encore on
veut goûter nombreux sont les français
qui consomment de l'aspergent le pays en
produit chaque année environ dix-huit
mille tonnes et une partie d'entre elles
est cultivé dans le sud touraine autour
de richelieu depuis quelques semaines
elles pointent le bout de leur nez par
centaines
reportage chez une productrice lucas
chopin elle pointe par dizaines au
milieu de ses champs les asperges du
riche les sont bonnes a récolté est
aujourd'hui c'est stéphanie qui s'y
colle entre avril et juin cette
productrice bio en accueille jusqu'à une
tonne et demie par semaine elles sont
cueillies tous les matins pour les
vertes et les pauvres on ne peut y
passer jusqu'à deux fois par jour le
matin et le soir
ça pousse très vite il faut seulement
les éplucher enfin surtout pour les
blanches de là bas jusqu'à la tête mais
une bonne partie
et sinon pour les vertes et des pourpres
seulement le pied sera sera épluché le
reste est consommable entièrement mais
avant cette étape de dégustation un
travail de longue haleine est nécessaire
ici chaque jour une dizaine de personnes
s'affairent pour rendre ces pousses
parfaite pour la consommation donc là
les asperges sont cueillies auxquels
sont elles sont lavées stockés dans
l'eau en attendant les places et donc en
citation reprise une seconde fois ici
pour qu'elle soit pour que la machine et
coupez les fruits à l'autre bout il ya
deux autres personnes qui qui les
remettent dans les quêtes approprié et
ensuite elles font reprises pour être
emballée ces asperges et stéphanie les
vend directement sur son exploitation
sur des marchés de gros ou par
correspondance mais aussi à brasles ou
une commune voisine qui organise chaque
année un marché de l'aspergent c'est la
mairesse claudine leclerc qui s'en
occupe depuis sa création en 1996 depuis
ce marché est devenu une véritable
institution dans le riche l'est on a des
gens qui viennent de loin aussi bien de
tourcom de poitiers et les gens
repartent
non ce n'est pas ça pas avec un kilo
d'aspergés
il repart vraiment avec 5 kg 10 kg les
gens font les conserves
oui énormément de succès le marché se
tiendra à brasles ou ce dimanche 9 mai
de quoi faire du sud touraine
une fois encore la capitale de
l'aspergent